or what's the funniest sport on steroids
that would be funny [ __ ] the uh dog
shows but the dog's on steroids the
walkers on steroids
just like come on
come on you goddamn
[Music]
is anybody familiar with the NASA Dart
yeah Bart knows yeah what is it it's the
day area responsive team that that's
Dara why do they need a response team
for the day why because sometimes they
go where'd the Sun come from Jay area
day area
sounds really good
um it is actually the pro program that
they within the last two weeks launched
towards an asteroid to see if it can
through crashing into it can bump it off
of its course I heard about that my trip
is this [ __ ] happened all the time yeah
they haven't figured out how to destroy
it they landed one on um like an
asteroid years ago to like just see
like what like well today like took a
sample from it oh and then they sent
that the material or they sent like what
the information is about the material
back there got it I think I've just been
seeing too many movies with this plot
probably this is Dara or dark dirt sorry
DACA it was dark
um but yeah uh basically uh less than
two weeks ago a telescope uh out in
Chile had captured the moment Dan was
crazy construction out there
um that the comment like
today's so tough uh a telescope in
Shelly caught the moment that uh or the
after moments where the asteroid was
struck and it created basically like a
kilometers thousands of kilometers a
length tail of debris oh [ __ ] but they
still don't have the actual data yet
because it just happened of whether or
not the there's a new course for the
asteroid this is a test in order to
anticipate the big moment when an
asteroid is coming to us oh okay that's
cool so that when the real ones come in
they know hey this worked so this is the
first test so even that very first time
the Astro wasn't heading at Earth it was
heading like towards our Direction but
they needed to grab samples in order to
figure a bunch of different stuff out
and whatnot this time they actually
crashed the [ __ ] probe into the
asteroid and they got all these like
little calculations and [ __ ] like that
yeah for example how [ __ ] funny would
it be if for the test one they blew it
up and then it went towards Earth
it changed its course to earth that is
space humor 2000. yeah yeah it's a space
meme or like just like killed our moon
or something like that
like that Moon fall movie that was
terrible that just came out moonfall so
this this right here I need it in a
German can you explain this in German
please God why is it dark is it German
no it's just better like that oh okay I
don't even know what the [ __ ] I'm
looking at this is NASA it's even better
these threats here is this is the
original orbits uh we are circling the
atmosphere at the demos
don't break character Jesus Christ
read this part here what does that say
NASA spacecraft crashes into
asteroids Moon
be more angry about it though say that
one more time this is really angry talk
about the dart uh we are going to send
the dot into the damn office that's
impact will alter the orbit Nick Nick
Nick I'll just give you a little note
you're thinking about how they're
spending money on this [ __ ] not fixing
your potholes now try it again yeah
[Laughter]
don't bother me because I avoid them oh
[ __ ] no but like Ryan said you just
gotta kind of tap them and then sue the
city
yeah remember that I'm not gonna go I'm
always through the city I'm not gonna
see the city dude so yeah as as he's so
very very much so explained literally
this was the dark probe that they sent
and it's meant to impact
the asteroid do a German
Vietnamese Vietnamese Vietnamese
[Laughter]
gonna he go that way he boom he rocked
and then they go to the smaller Circle
man see that was really good oh man
oh God damn it did the big right at the
Dwayne Johnson
[Laughter]
has a circle man that's crazy dude
that's what we need in [ __ ] more Viet
spokesperson yeah dude I've been doing
this wrong the whole time we need more
Viet scientists oh God do you guys think
this shit's gonna work so easy to
understand through Viet I understood
everything why does it make more sense
do we think it's gonna work you're
asking this room if it's gonna work
we're the news team we're supposed to
get there's people out there that are
looking for answers
this is a credible Source blinking
because Steve you're you're really you
like this I love space love outer space
Cabo
your space so I feel like if anyone has
you know the authority to say it's going
to organize a beat there's literally a
hamster on a wheel right here in my
brain and it's just going on like that I
don't know what were you gonna say why'd
you have your hand up oh I said that I
vote Yes you're just voting he's still
voting I thought yes that it's gonna
work Bart goes into the boat in the
voting boothy
[Laughter]
do you want this to work I voted yes I
do what are some alternative techniques
to divert in asteroids
that yeah yeah all I know using sonic
waves all I know is the [ __ ] analogy
from Armageddon which is a very credible
movie where they talk about if you see
asteroid is impacted or no this is the
wrong ass energy point is it [ __ ]
hits top it's just gonna [ __ ] just
kind of shatter but you gotta blow it up
from the inside that's why we need Bruce
Willis to go drip
but that's such [ __ ] because all you
gotta do is move a little bit if it's
far enough away you just move a little
bit and then it goes way far away well
push yeah a little tiny little bit a
little little that's true little so
basically we have to we have to see the
asteroid coming in our direction from
really far away and then because it's
really far away we have to send our
probe a really long time before it meets
and then moving fast enough because
that's the problem too the trajectory
that [ __ ] is going to be like
pretty big time right so you want to
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to count on that you have to move real
fast yeah you have to do your
calculation everyone's overlooking one
very simple solution Why move the
asteroid blow up Earth and move Earth
out of the way oh that's sick idiot we
throw another asteroid into it to move
it if we if we explode enough nukes in
the atmosphere you think we'll move
Earth a little bit a little bit I think
we'll move it enough let's say that and
if everybody jumps up and down at the
same time across the world at the same
time you have to promise you're gonna
yeah yeah well they would have to all go
to one side of the world we have to know
the time zone we could do that yeah but
yeah we're spitballing here yeah you
could just blow up there's a huge part
of the ocean no one needs which part
[ __ ] all parts yeah honestly the
Pacific Ocean is a big [ __ ] miss in
my opinion
I've taken the day
Pacific Ocean big [ __ ] miss all right
what's a better ocean what's a better
Ocean than Pacific Indian Ocean Indian
Ocean's wave Indian
Ocean's killing it more than the Pacific
yeah dude
Pacific has the wackest rivers that come
out of it I think about Pacific I go pee
you
oh please [ __ ] it yeah dude move the
Earth stupid yeah you also think about
how they talk about like when an
asteroid comes and hits and for some
reason the movies always say it's gonna
be like life-ending Annihilation type
impact and then they always do this
[ __ ] graph where it's like it's gonna
hit the side and everything's gonna burn
and then after that there's gonna be an
Ice Age yeah I'm like wait a minute is
that really good for our planet right
about now don't we like need way more
icing but we're gonna all die we won't
experience it we got Mars for that well
I'm thinking Nicholas Cage and have him
steal the asteroid oh yeah
that is a good idea because he's
actually in the process of making that
movie he steals impossible things
already yeah he stole a [ __ ]
declaration independence cake too yeah
it was easy
crazy how long that [ __ ] fear has
been existent that [ __ ] was gonna hit
the earth like it's in the [ __ ] Bible
yeah or they talk about like there's a
[ __ ] they're saying it's hacky
comment yeah it's [ __ ] original or is
it something we should even worry about
if it happens we're all in [ __ ]
gonzos anyway I mean if you can prevent
that small talk right if you can prevent
it if I can get get a huge ass Jose
Canseco get that [ __ ] out of there who's
a can Seiko yeah get a [ __ ] breed
crossbreed get a [ __ ] Giant baseball
dude I would get a giant Berry bonds oh
my opinion not a [ __ ] Juiced up stuff
yeah yeah juice stuff yeah Juiced up so
he hits it in a [ __ ] Andromeda yeah
just hey dude everyone's talking about
that Yankees guy right now because he
hit 62. Barry Bonds hits [ __ ] 76 or
some [ __ ] yeah dude light work nobody
cares was very Bonds on drugs yeah yes
they should let baseball players be on
steroids yeah absolutely should baseball
all sports should be steroids should be
[ __ ] mutant League which sport should
not be on steroids or what's the
funniest sport on steroids that would be
funny [ __ ] the uh dog shows but the
dog's on steroids the walkers on
steroids
just like come on yeah God damn
well I thought you meant like power
walkers but on steroids no I mean the
Walkers who were walking the dogs or the
guy just stacked the guy who examines
the dog says on steroids who puts his
hand in their ass oh no what about like
dart throwing but on steroids it feels
like it's already kind of royalty to me
I feel like they don't those guys don't
get
so lame probably bowling that'd be cool
whoa
I'm gonna take that as soon as I said it
I [ __ ] take it back it's okay we'll
edit out for you because you look like a
[ __ ] idiot for that one [ __ ]
bobsled on steroids they're sitting and
they're just shaking
but that push will be a good push oh
what's the curling curling will be
curling on steroids dude they're just
going down into the ice but make it way
bigger you know what I mean make
wherever they play where do they play in
an ice rink yeah they need to get rid of
some sports uh what's called
shuffleboard uh what did I just say it's
curly curling is pretty is that this one
yeah
shuffleboard and curling is the same
thing bro you're just sweeping the floor
before the [ __ ] ball thing gets you
see how fast they sweep though it's
pretty cool what about some of the
throwing ones do you think those should
stay like you got Javelin you have like
shot put shot put should be rewarded out
for sure
Javelin too all of them people should be
in the audience they should be [ __ ]
sweating like they should have they
should be sweating if it's gonna hit
them yeah bring the bleachers even
closer they gotta put a Splash Zone a
[ __ ] Shamu Splash Zone dude you'll be
crazy on Roy's [ __ ] synchronized
swimming
hope they all sink to the bottom dude
the person doesn't have to they can't
float yeah it's like damn just [ __ ]
with our boy yeah dude they're gonna
stink that's what I'm hoping for the
show ended so quick put NASCAR on Roy's
dude dude NASCAR is pretty sweet because
then nothing would change at all
everybody's crashing they need more
synchronized Sports
just take it make eight guys do it at
the same time do you think dance would
be different dude do you think dance
would be different dance would be out of
here on roids steroids
redo ABDC b-boys would be crazy that's
what I'm saying you redo ABDC but then
you guys all have to do steroids you
just look like Chippendales yeah we
probably lose a lot of our flexibility
and Mobility like no Mobility yeah
they're sexy as hell
[Music]